cuándo
[Música]
11 mineros que quedaron atrapados 600
metros bajo tierra desde hace 14 días
tras una explosión fueron rescatados y
se encuentran en buena condición en la
provincia de shangdong en china de los
22 mineros al menos uno murió y aún no
se tienen noticias de los otros 10
la jornada de protestas a nivel nacional
en rusia exigiendo la liberación del
líder opositor alexei naval y se saldó
con más de 3000 detenidos la unión
europea de floro el uso de la fuerza por
parte de las autoridades y la nueva
administración de joe biden pidió la
inmediata liberación de la habana
tenemos el reporte desde moscú
avanza una típica jornada electoral en
portugal donde en medio de una profunda
crisis por el cob y 19 los ciudadanos
van a las urnas para elegir a un nuevo
presidente marcelo reveló de souza
actualmente en el cargo aspira a una
cómoda reelección tenemos reporte en
esta emisión de noticias
buenos días bienvenidos al informativo
de france 24 mi nombre es andrés espinal
comenzamos en china donde al menos 11 de
los 22 mineros que quedaron atrapados
bajo tierra hace dos semanas pudieron
finalmente ver la luz tras una intensa
operación de rescate en una mina en la
provincia de shandong aún no se sabe
nada de otros diez de ellos veamos
este minero puede sentirse aliviado de
estar por fin al aire libre durante dos
semanas estuvo atrapado a cientos de
metros bajo tierra con sus otros 21
compañeros una explosión arrojó
escombros al pozo del ascensor de la
mina bloqueando por completo la salida
mientras el agua subterránea empezaba a
subir si no fuera por los cientos de
rescatistas que se apresuraron al lugar
y perforaron agujeros para enviar comida
agua y medicinas él y sus compañeros
podrían haber muerto
los rescatistas revisaron a los mineros
para ver si tenían heridas y cubrieron
sus ojos para protegerse en general la
operación de rescate procedió más rápido
de lo esperado después de sacar a todos
los mineros que encontramos
continuaremos con la búsqueda de los
otros desaparecidos
este gráfico muestra lo que han hecho
los rescatistas tras la explosión
localizaron a 11 de los 22 mineros que
trabajaban en el momento del incidente a
unos 580 metros de profundidad los
rescatistas hallaron a otro hombre en un
pozo 100 metros más abajo durante días
se comunicaron con ellos y continuaron
perforando mientras descendía para
buscarlo encontraron a otro minero
varado con el que no habían estado en
contacto en estas imágenes se ve que el
hombre ni siquiera puede ponerse en pie
primero nos encargamos del caso más
crítico este es el principio en el
rescate de accidentes mineros
entonces priorizamos los casos de
condiciones físicas y psicológicas más
delicados
los rescatistas tienen pocas esperanzas
para otros 10 mineros de los que no han
tenido noticias desde la explosión los
accidentes son comunes en las minas de
china porque las regulaciones de
seguridad no siempre se hacen cumplir
aún así el número total de muertes ha
disminuido en los últimos años a medida
que las autoridades aumentan la
supervisión
jornada de fuerte represión en rusia
tras las multitudinarias protestas que
exigían la inmediata liberación del
opositor alexéi navalni que fue
arrestado tras regresar al país la
semana pasada la policía detuvo a más de
3000 personas en el país
el kremlin acusó a eeuu de una supuesta
injerencia en los asuntos domésticos
rusos desde moscú nuestro corresponsal
corresponsal xavier colás con los
detalles
no se ha vivido una histórica jornada de
protestas y a estas horas según las
organizaciones de derechos humanos la
cifra de detenidos en todo el país
supera los tres mil también hay heridos
manifestantes y también agentes puesto
que la brutalidad que vimos ayer en las
protestas por ejemplo aquí en moscú no
la veíamos desde hacía mucho tiempo
también contemplamos escenas poco
habituales como ciudadanos
rodeando y atacando a los agentes en
este caso con bolas de nieve en medio de
la calle tanto estaba centrada la
manifestación y las movilizaciones de
ayer en la figura de nava ni que aquí en
moscú cuando acabaron las protestas
algunos grupos de manifestantes
marcharon hasta la prisión de madrid
óscar y sina donde está preso alexéi
navalni hasta allí a la espera de que un
juicio decida el próximo 2 de febrero si
tiene que cumplir una nueva condena de
cárcel
pasamos a venezuela donde el presidente
nicolás maduro aseguró que aspira a unas
nuevas relaciones con eeuu
ahora que joe biden está en el poder
tras unas tensas relaciones con el
expresidente trump maduro pidió a
washington voltear la página y se
declaró listo para emprender un nuevo
camino con el presidente estadounidense
entrante sin embargo anthony blinken
nominado por joe biden para el cargo de
secretario de estado dijo que el líder
de la casa blanca planea seguir
reconociendo a juan guaidó como el líder
legítimo del país suramericano
escuchemos a nicolás maduro esta
venezuela del siglo 21 bolivariana y
revolucionaria está dispuesta a pasar la
página y a construir nuevos caminos de
respeto diálogo y comunicación
diplomática con el gobierno de joe
vaivén sobre la base del respeto mutuo
el diálogo la comunicación y el
entendimiento en temas de interés mutuo
y vamos ahora a portugal donde se
desarrolla una jornada electoral que
definirá al nuevo presidente en medio de
una profunda crisis por el cob y 19
votar es el único motivo por el cual los
ciudadanos tienen permitido salir de sus
hogares a parte de los desplazamientos
esenciales por motivos laborales
modificar la fecha de los comicios
habría implicado a hacer cambios a la
constitución del país según las
encuestas marcelo reveló de souza
actualmente en el cargo obtendría
cómodamente la reelección sus
contrincantes
anna gómez de izquierda y andrew
aventuras de ultraderecha obtienen entre
un 13.5 a 14.5 por ciento y un 10 a 12.5
por ciento respectivamente en la
intención de voto desde un centro de
votación en cascais en el área
metropolitana de lisboa conectamos con
nuestra corresponsal
daniela zambrano daniela buenos días
cuéntenos cómo avanza la jornada
electoral y a pesar de que las encuestas
auguran una victoria cómoda para marcelo
reveló de souza existe la posibilidad de
una segunda vuelta
hola qué tal esto es uno de los
principales centros de votación en
cascais y pese a lo que decían todos los
sondeos de una abstención cercana al 60%
pues se ha visto totalmente lo contrario
una afluencia de votantes en
prácticamente todos los centros de
votación tanto en el centro como el
interior del país incluso también en
madera me permito mostrar las imágenes
las filas de las personas a la espera
para ejercer el derecho al voto este ha
sido una constante es bastante rápido el
proceso las personas guardan
distanciamiento sin embargo tardan entre
15 y 20 minutos en poder ejercer su
derecho al voto también todas las
encuestas apuntan como lo decías a que
marcelo reveló de souza gane en la
reelección sin embargo para esto tendrá
que obtener el 50 por ciento de los
votos de lo contrario sin ningún
candidato lo obtiene habrá una segunda
vuelta el próximo 14 de febrero
básicamente en todo el país se ha
registrado unas elecciones en calma y
con alta influencia sin embargo ha visto
ha habido algunas incidencias por
ejemplo en uno de los centros de
votación en haber o un grupo de personas
pero texto
para cerrar un centro de votación porque
en esas frases y as hacen falta médicos
y consideraban muy respeto que hay
elecciones pero no haya atención
suficiente en los hospitales
muy bien daniela y estas elecciones se
producen a pesar de que el país está
gravemente afectado por la pandemia de
kobe 19 qué medidas se han tomado para
garantizar la seguridad de los votantes
y cuéntanos cuál es la situación general
en portugal
si es bastante de crítica la situación
en portugal se habla de más de 1000
personas fallecidas en los últimos cinco
días las emergencias y los cuidados
intensivos en el hospital es
prácticamente colapsados la medida que
ha tomado el gobierno para garantizar la
seguridad de los ciudadanos y que salgan
a votar es que sea obligatorio el uso de
las máscaras que cada persona tenga que
traer su bolígrafo para poder ejercer el
derecho al voto que se cumple el
distanciamiento y han colocado más mesas
de votación menos electores por mesa más
centros de votación en todo el país
también que se desinfecten las manos
cada vez que vayan a ingresar y esto es
básicamente el llamado que hacen a la
ciudadanía de hecho como decías salir a
votar es prácticamente una de las únicas
excepciones este fin de semana para
poder salir de casa
muchas gracias daniela por el completo
reporte pasamos a las noticias
relacionadas con el cob y 19 en américa
latina' el oxígeno es un elemento vital
para los pacientes que sufren de
problemas respiratorios consecuencia del
virus en países como méjico la escasez
de tanques de oxígeno y el aumento de
hasta en 4 veces su precio está
agravando la situación de muchas
personas que viven apenas con un salario
mínimo y tienen familiares enfermos
andrés amaya nos cuenta la historia
5 horas de fila para una hora de oxígeno
diariamente cientos de personas llegan a
esta calle en ciudad de méxico para
comprar oxígeno vital para sus seres
queridos con hobby 19 la mayoría debe
esperar para recargar un tanque que a
veces solo dura una hora
estos tanques hitos no son suficientes
entonces con esto
teníamos que llenarlos de 4 a 5 veces al
día y noche
entonces corren ley y se ha acabado uno
y aún a alguien se tenía que venir a
formar y el otro porque aquí es el único
lugar que que son 24 horas de alguien
fuera en ningún otro lado consigues
llevamos aproximadamente aquí hoy un
compañerito de tres a cuatro días todos
los días aquí todo el tiempo hasta en la
madrugada por el tipo de pacientes que
tenemos mal que son varios no son unos
no son varios entonces tenemos que estar
aquí rellenando el día y noche nuestros
tanques de oxígeno
con 9 millones de habitantes ciudad de
méxico- está en alerta máxima desde el
18 de diciembre los hospitales tienen
una ocupación del 90 por ciento con la
rapidez con que el cob y 19 se ha
propagado en la población
en días anteriores el gobierno aseguró
que hay suficiente suministro de oxígeno
clínico sin embargo la realidad en las
calles es otra cómo la demanda supera la
oferta los distribuidores cobran hasta
cuatro veces más por una recarga el
precio varía entre 160 a 990 dólares el
tanque de oxígeno a esto se suma los
precios en el mercado ilegal que se
abastece con tanques robados en empresas
u hospitales y que venden a precios
exorbitantes actualmente más de 17
millones de personas se han contagiado
en méxico y más de 149.000 han perdido
la batalla contra el jove 19
avanzan las campañas de vacunación en
los países de la unión europea donde se
han registrado retrasos en las entregas
de las dosis de facer y el laboratorio
astrazéneca comunicó demoras por
problemas de producción francia un país
que ha recibido críticas por un proceso
de inoculación lento ya superó el millón
de vacunados sin embargo muchos centros
han tenido que cerrar sus puertas debido
a la falta del fármaco
abrir para volver a cerrar en sólo
cuatro días
este centro de vacunación en un suburbio
del centro de parís se quedó sin vacunas
así que todas las citas pendientes
tuvieron que suspenderse un des que
esperamos que no sonó fuerte hasta junio
huayhua en otro centro el demo a una
hora al norte de parís se repite la
misma historia 200 citas tuvieron que
ser reprogramadas porque no había
vacunas
tuvimos que parar pronto porque no
quedaban vacunas
por desgracia tuvimos que volver a mucha
gente que había venido y ahora tenemos
que cerrar este centro inicialmente eso
también este centro en antena tuvo que
cerrar todo por la tarde de manera
temporal hasta el gimnasio que había
sido reabierto como centro de vacunación
estaba listo para albergar a filas de
personas y ese todo a la vez normalmente
a esta hora debería haber enfermeras
vacunas
exide en aquellos centros todavía
abiertos como éste de mullus los
pacientes señalan que conseguir una cita
fue una odisea es un alivio haber
conseguido una cita eso seguro y el
stoke actual necesita ser reemplazado
ya quedan pocas existencias ahora mismo
tenemos lo suficiente para las próximas
dos semanas el plan del gobierno es
vacunar a 4 millones de personas para
finales de febrero tras el décimo
aniversario de la primavera árabe
tunecina el 14 de enero regresaron las
protestas los protagonistas son los
jóvenes cansados de la falta de
oportunidades hace poco más de un año
los tunecinos votaron a caixa jet como
presidente el 90% de sus votantes era
menor de 35 años sin embargo las
esperanzas de una renovación se han
diluido y la ira ha vuelto a las calles
ni policía ni islamistas el pueblo
quiere revolución es uno de los gritos
en túnez diez años después de la
primavera árabe la crisis es aún peor
también la represión 1200 jóvenes entre
15 y 25 años han sido detenidos desde el
14 de enero por si sales a protestar
morirás yo hasta la escuela morirás en
este país todo lo que hagas estará
condenado te a muerte siempre hay
represión policial este sábado se
repitió el patrón de las últimas semanas
en túnez la capital y en otras ciudades
del país durante el día
protestas por la situación social cuando
llega la noche disturbios en un país
donde el tercio de los jóvenes está
desempleado a donde viva túnez que se
vayan todos los políticos y nos dejen en
paz ocuparemos las calles o nosotros o
ellos el estallido comenzó el 14 de
enero cuando se conmemoraban 10 años de
la expulsión del dictador ben alí el
proceso de democratización no ha acabado
de consolidarse y en los últimos meses
la crisis política económica y laboral
se ha agravado con la pandemia del cob y
19 que en las últimas jornadas ha
llegado a dejar
de 100 muertos diarios las protestas se
concentran en los barrios trabajadores y
la respuesta del gobierno tecnócrata
está siendo represión y toques de queda
por el virus una crisis más grave que la
de 1.011 con una generación más
castigada que se ve obligada a mirar más
allá como los cerca de 13.000 tunecinos
que salieron en 2020 de forma irregular
en su mayoría hacia italia siga con más
de en france 24